lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es que
practiquemos encontrar áreas de
superficies de figuras abriendo las y
formando lo que llamamos red es una
forma de pensar en ello es que si
tenemos una figura como ésta que está
hecha de cartón si nosotros la cortamos
justo en donde estoy señalando aquí aquí
también y aquí atrás se abriría en algo
parecido a esto si la abrimos nos
quedará algo así y al abrirla es mucho
más fácil calcular el área de la
superficie de la figura en el caso de
esta figura el área de la superficie va
a ser la suma del área de cada una de
estas partes de aquí al base del área de
la superficie de esto que estoy
resaltando en azul en la red corresponde
a esta área de aquí es un triángulo y
tiene una base de 12 y una altura de 8
el área de esta parte va a ser un medio
por 12 por la altura que es 8
esto es lo mismo que 6 por 8 y nos da 48
cualquiera que sean sus unidades van a
ser estas unidades al cuadrado y aquí
arriba tenemos exactamente lo mismo
no podemos verla en esta figura pero si
fuera transparente sería este lado de
atrás y también tendrá 48 unidades
cuadradas de área ahora podemos
considerar el área de lo que podemos
decir son los paneles laterales
este es un panel lateral tiene 14 de
altura y 10 de base este lado de aquí
mide lo mismo que este otro de acá por
lo que va a medir 14 unidades de altura
y 10 de anchura
este panel lateral es este de aquí el
área de cada uno de estos paneles es 14
x 10 lo que nos da 140 unidades
cuadradas esto también tiene 140
unidades cuadradas y finalmente nos
queda calcular el área de esto que
podríamos llamar la base de la figura
esto que estoy resaltando en amarillo
que es esta área de acá y va a ser de 12
x 14
esta área mide 12 x 14 que es igual
veamos 12 x 12 144 más otros 24 nos da
168 y ahora vamos a calcular el área
total de esta figura vamos a sumar las
áreas que tenemos estas dos son 48 48
nos da 96 tenemos estos paneles
laterales que son 140 140 es igual a 280
más nuestra base que mide 168
si sumamos todo esto tendremos el área
total y vemos que es muy valioso abrir
esta figura en esta red porque nos
facilita encontrar el área de cada uno
de los lados y así sumarlo en lugar de
imaginarnos esta figura y rotarla en
nuestra mente para ver los lados que no
podemos ver aunque también podríamos
hacerlo 6 + 8 es igual a 14 pongo el 4
aquí y me decena la reagrupa acá 19 10
10 + 8 es 18 18 624 escribo el 4 y mis
dos centenas las reagrupó aquí dos más
dos son cuatro
unas cinco nos queda que el área total
de la superficie de esta figura
quinientos cuarenta y cuatro centímetros
cuadrados